hi everyone
my name is gabriel martinez i'm
currently the head of advanced imaging
at the gulbenkian institute you know it
is in portugal
i've also been teaching bioimaging for
the last 12 years of
a lot since university of lisbon i hope
this webinar finds you in good health
and spirit
in this troubled times we're living and
i want to thank you for taking
time to watch this this webinar and also
thank claudia and susan for giving me
the opportunity to present this work
these beautiful images that we have been
obtaining with this
still fairly unknown technique um
which i believe has a lot of potential
and
should get more attention from cell and
developmental biologists
and i want to start by giving you a
brief overview of
where optical thermography fits in the
landscape of multiple optical
imaging techniques that we have these
days which can range from thermoscopy
the
observation of individual molecules all
the way up to
overstepping already in the medical
field of imaging
now typically most of you i believe are
microscopists
are familiarized with samples on this
range
microscopy range with magnifications up
to
60 or 100x where you can see you know
with fair amount of detail inside even
individual cells now if one cell is
represented as
this little dot on the screen here you
have this
whole range of samples that we can out
these days actually
put in the microscope and obtain
fairly detailed information even
three-dimensional information
off confocal is probably the most common
technique that most of you are
familiarized with and used
probably on a daily basis and you know
that with confocal microscopy you can
generate
three-dimensional images so to speak in
fact you don't generate
three-dimensional images but you obtain
optical slices of a three-dimensional
sample to a convocal microscopy
if you're lucky to have a two-photon set
up on your lab
you know that you can actually image
deeper so get a larger chunk of
three-dimensional tissue where you can
obtain information from if you're a
developmental biologist very often this
isn't enough
for example if you want to hemorrhage a
whole zebra fish developing
over the course of 24 hours and the
whole zipper fish is 10 times larger
than you typically can
fit with high quality on
a field of view of a confocal microscope
so you end up resorting to other
techniques
relatively recent techniques now this
range of sample sizes
that falls in between the typical
microscopy and
up to the macro or medical imaging field
is become known as the mesoscopic scale
or mesoscale and mesoscopic imaging
and and there are many techniques but
the two most prominent techniques that i
have addressed the challenges of these
large samples
have been light sheet which i'm familiar
most of you have already
seen heard of or even used and
optical tomography which extends even a
little bit beyond the range of light
to most light sheet systems now
what are the samples that you typically
want to image with light sheet or
optical tomography
as i said very large samples like a
whole zebra fish embryo or even larger
like a whole mouse embryo here
represented
by this little image here or a sample
that is about six millimeters
long now these actually dwarf in
comparison to the size of this av and
embryo that you see here in the back
it's actually halfway more than halfway
through development it's huge it's very
large so you would never put this in a
microscope and expect to see
with detail the whole sample and that's
where optical tomography really excels
is in
providing you with a possibility
obtaining these fairly large images
now i've already alluded to the fact
that we're talk typically about
three-dimensional imaging
um using optical slicing as you normally
use
for example confocal microscopy the
paradigm
for three-dimensional imaging in medical
fields and even
in optical microscopy is still pretty
much
that you image large image and handle
images of large volumes
as a series of optical sections this is
known generically as tomography
the word tomography is more common in
medical imaging
and not so much in them in optical
microscopy but in fact confocal
microscopy
light sheet microscopy our form of
tomography
now you can obtain these tomographic
series or
um z stacks of optical sections as we
normally know them in optical microscopy
in both a direct and an indirect matter
if you're
illuminating the whole sample
simultaneously as you normally do with
wide field microscopy
you don't really get optical slices
because you're seeing everything
including the narrow depth of field
where the
the the optical system is providing you
with the maximum
contrast but also everything that's out
of focus and it's extremely difficult
to obtain a tomogram when you're doing
up
when you're doing imaging in right field
elimination and detection mode
now you can be a bit more um
more precise more selective in how you
either illuminate
or detect your
your signal from your sample and that's
what you do with confocal microscopy
where you kind of selectively eliminate
point by point the sample
and you're very selective in how you
detect
the light that emanates from that point
that is swept across your sample
sequentially the the the disadvantage
that you know of conflict microscopy is
that you're
you're still illuminating the whole
sample and you're subjecting all of the
cells and all the tissues even the ones
that you're not imaging
to very intense radiation which is not
very healthy
lychee microscopy is a great revolution
started
15 years ago and that it completely
changed
the way that we illuminate samples it's
a selective method of illuminating your
sample
which allows you to detect image and
generate and detect
fluorescence only exactly on the optical
slice that you're trying to image
and then allow developmental biologists
to observe embryos
by much longer periods and in much
better health conditions
than it was typically possible there was
a huge hype
rightfully so about the development of
light cheek microscopy in the last
10 years at least which kind of
overshadowed a little bit
the development of optical tomography
now just to to to reiterate again what
optical tomography and where
it fits with white field illumination
you can actually also obtain
optical slices and typically you need to
do that by computing by using some form
of
computer power to derive optical slices
from the
raw images that you obtain white field
deconvolution is probably the most
common method which i'm sure most of you
are familiarized with you can obtain
white field images and if you're fairly
confident about
your knowledge on the point spread
function of your system you can actually
guess
or derive optical sections but that has
a limited depth you cannot really go
very far
and you won't see normally deconvolution
applied to imaging large embryos
the other technique that i'm talking
about today
which also relies on computing optical
slices
from a white field image is computed
tomography or
more commonly known as optical
projection tomography
it's aching to medical imaging and we
will see in a moment how it operates
and this is where i'll be concentrating
my the rest of my talk today
so a few years ago we started a project
with
an institute to develop a fully open
source
um my cheat microscopy and now i joined
the group
and started collaborating with the group
of nunu and emilio back then
and we decided that we wanted to get a
system that was not just
fully open source but it was also
capable of doing
not just achieve microscopy but also
optical tomography which we believe were
two very interesting techniques
that required um further development and
opening to the community now
um as most of you probably know
there was another project going on at
the same time called
the open spin project and um
we just found out as we were working on
this that they were all
also working on the same project and
even had the same name for the
technology
so we we kind of we kind of joked and
came up with a different ink on open
spin microscopy instead of open spin
microscopy as it's
fairly well known and very well
documented on the internet
the the term spin here refers to the
fact that we're focusing on
the the high precision of rotation of
samples that you could do
this in this case representation here a
fairly simple setup
but which actually allowed you to do
optical tomography
now where did the optical tomography
come from and what does it do what kind
of problems does it address well if you
want to image
large samples as i've shown you you can
use some kind of animal
small animal imager but you will not
going to get three-dimensional imaging
most of the times which is what we want
you have destructive techniques like
episcopic tomography where
it actually physically slices the sample
slice by slice progressively
and you can obtain a three-dimensional
reconstruction but the sample is gone by
the end and it's fairly technically
complex to attain
or you can resort to these very
expensive cumbersome techniques like
micro mri or even a synchrotron facility
which costs in the ranges of millions of
euros and thousands of euros an hour to
operate
and they're very low throughput you're
lucky to get
one sample every day
the other alternative which is typically
not available to
microscopys and developmental biologists
is a micro x-ray ct scanner which you
will find very often in engineering
departments
the problem of micro ct scans is that
they are not designed
to operate with transparent samples with
biological samples that
that don't have uh radio opacity
if you put an embryo inside of one of
these machines it's too transparent for
x-rays and you won't be able to see
anything now there's beautiful work done
with microswitches
out there which requires basically
preparing the sample with some kind of
radio epic
chemical but it's still not a relative
it's not
very common or an easy technique for
most biologists
thinking of that james sharp developed
and then later created a company
that created a optical tomography
scanner for light instead of x-rays
now how does it work well in medical
imaging
when if you want to obtain information
about the inside of the human body or
any other huge sample you need to resort
to x-rays
biological materials are transparent to
x-rays as it goes through the
biological material you can detect an
image on the other side and basically
get a shadow image
if you rotate the detector and the x-ray
source
around the object the person you can
obtain images from all the angles and
then compute
what is and slice computed slice the
computer
generates this now the process is known
as generically as back projection
reconstruction
and if you see here this image you can
try to create something
kind of similar where you have a sample
in front of a camera
that is rotating and you're acquiring
images from all the angles you use the
exact same algorithms to reconstruct
this image
line by line as you see here in this
movie if you go line by line you can
actually reconstruct this
um each one of these axial levels or
planes
along this this movie of the sample
rotating
and then generate optical slices the
technique is pretty much the same as
using medical fields
james sharp first developed this in 2002
and as i said it was a company that
lasted for about
a few years up until 2012 i believe 2010
or 2012
and then the technique was no longer
available why cheat microscopy
came of age people started getting
really excited about light sheet
microscopy and they sort of forgot about
optical tomography and it's a pity
because
as i will try to convince you today it
generates really really interesting
images
and it's far more accessible to build
and operate and maintain
than a light sheet microscope now one of
the great things about the light sheet
microscopy
is that it brought huge developments to
the field and it's still ongoing right
now
and it's becoming more and more
challenging to biologists
to get their hands on the latest
high-end light sheet microscope or even
choosing which one is the best for the
research because
there are so many options these days
optical tomography has had a fair amount
of development but not as much
not as much hype as legit microscopy and
as i said it's much simpler to get your
hands into
and i will try to convince you that it's
worth your time
now as we were developing the open spin
um project where where we
gave everyone access to blueprints and
and
even software and the hardware
instructions
um of the open speed microscopy project
we also started developing the opent
which was
sort of a spinoff of the openspin
project
a simpler version of a setup that would
do
just optical tomography um
and you can find this information online
as well you can contact me and i'll
direct you to where you can find all of
this information on how to build your
your very simple optical tomography
setup with just
a few thousand two thousand errors or
even less you can build a
fairly usable and very interesting setup
you don't need lasers you don't need
very expensive high-end cameras you can
even use an industrial camera
very simple industrial cameras
represented in this diagram here you can
build your own illuminator
and in this case you use simply a
um an arduino controller to
run the whole setup it's fairly fairly
simple
so is it worth your time
the other thing i want to tell you about
is the fact that very often
you don't especially if you're dealing
with late stage embryos you don't want
to
do very high magnifications in fact you
may
actually want to do d magnification you
want
to image something that's larger than
your chip the chip on your camera so
very often in
optical tomography instead of using one
two four x
10x magnification um as you do with
light sheet microscopy you may actually
use
less than one x magnification like zero
like in this case here
we have d magnifying telecentric lens
it which provides a 0.3 x magnification
now as long as the chip on your camera
has lots of pixels
and your optics are good enough to fill
those
pixels with actual information then you
you
then you're getting detail of something
that's large
but you're getting the tail of small
structures inside something that's
fairly large
now the other thing which i believe i
failed to mention yeah is that optical
tomography for this very large samples
relies on your ability to see through
the samples just like with x-rays you
have to see through
the sample see what's inside and
reconstruct the anatomy from the inside
also with optical tomography the samples
have to be fairly transparent
now this is not a requisite only of
optical tomography
light sheet microscopy will also not
give you details inside
a sample that's not transparent enough
the same thing for confocal or even two
photon microscopy
the illuminating light needs to go
through the sample and it's get inside
for you to actually see what's inside
with optical tomography this is
extremely important you actually have to
see through the whole sample in order to
reconstruct
a proper optical section later in the
process
so that's one um one reason why
typically you only see optical
tomography applied to dead
fixed and cleared samples but we if you
get proper clearing
and fairly well mounted samples and
cleared samples you do get amazing
results
even with a fairly simple much simpler
than this setup
than what you're seeing here in this
image now another interesting thing
about
optical tomography is that
you can operate both in fluorescence
mode as most
developmental biologists are used to
from using
confocal microscopy fluorescence
microscopy or for example even
light sheet microscopy but you can also
operate in bright field mode
now because we normally want to do
three-dimensional imaging
on confocal microscopy you cannot do
three-dimensional imaging using
transmitted light even though you can
image with transmitted light
but in fact with optical tomography you
can use also
transmitted light as in this example
here
and with that obtain optical slices
compute the optical slices as long as
the sample is transparent enough
and here this this rabbit embryo is
shown inside an agarose block after it
was
rendered transparent by a tissue
clearing technique
typically we use a combination of
benzene alcohol and benzoyl benz weight
we call the abd for clearing this and
imaging these samples in optical
tomography but
there are many other techniques for
clearing tissues these days
which are being explored and which might
have applications in optical tomography
as well
after you've obtained the series of
optical sections by computation as i
said
you can then reconstruct
three-dimensionally and do these three
3d renderings of your z stack
now how good are these images is it
worth it to build this thing
well this is an example of a fairly
large but still small
sample it's a six millimeter
mouse embryo um at i believe
14 days of development a little bit
beyond halfway through development
and um it's probably not quite clear to
you at this point but one of the
advantages of optical tomography
is that these
these images are isotropic you can get
the same resolution no matter which
angle you look from
and if you've tried to look at the
confocal stack
from a different angle you will you
probably have gone through the
frustration of seeing oh
it's a lot worse i can't see the detail
so well
with light sheet microscopy that can be
addressed by imaging from multiple sites
and doing what's called multi-view
reconstruction where you merge
different views from different angles of
the sample and with that
increase the the contrast and the detail
on your
volumes but that's computationally
cumbersome it takes quite a while
to do depending on the size of your
sample and the level of resolution that
you're trying to achieve
with light sheet microscopy with optical
tomography you don't have to worry about
that
because you're imaging through all of
the angles of a sample rotating you can
see it from all of the angles that's the
only way you can get an optical slice
is by actually imaging from all the
angles so when you reconstruct it in 3d
you still have to go through a
computational process but when you do
that
you obtain a data set that's isometric
now not always easy not always beautiful
with optical tomography and in this case
you can actually
see that there's some artifacts as well
for example some edge artifacts
or there seem to be some rays pointing
in this direction here
these are artifacts caused by either
something that was
very fluorescent inside your sample or
very dark
where we can get much information from
or
bubbles air bubbles in your sample again
keep in mind that this is a problem for
any technique even light cheat
microscopy very often you don't realize
this until you've reconstructed it in 3d
with optical tomography once you've
reconstructed it in 3d you realize that
these
um artifacts are in there and if you
don't use this technology
well you end up getting lots of
artifacts
we'll get back to that um later on in
this talk
now we we kept on pushing the limits of
with the apex
and the the the amount of information we
can get
from this and we decided to do something
a little bit larger six times larger
actually this is a pop mouse button
is born and we were at this point
getting a 4 megapixel camera
and we got this amazing results you
don't always get these amazing results
this one is actually stunning it's
incredible how much detail you can get
and and bear in mind that you're not
really seeing the full resolution
of this um this is a six gig of voxel
data set that we obtained from this
3.6 centimeter long
mouse pop and the resolution that you
obtain with this
is around um if i if i'm not mistaken
about
10 to 20 microns actually about 10
microns of resolution which is you know
not
cellular resolution but you know tissue
level resolution
this is 3d virtual histology you don't
have to section the embryo the embryo is
still sitting in our lab in a fl
in a flask we still have it and every
now and then we try to image it again
for tests
in in this case this embryo was actually
very very transparent very the the
tissue cleaning worked
really well and we were able to obtain
these amazing results
so we decided well how far can we go
and in fact the the extent of where we
could go was
put to the test when a colleague from
australia
called us and said you know uh we have
this bioptonic scanner that cannot scan
the whole
series of quail embryos and we would
like to do
an anatomy um database that includes
images from
all of the stages not just the very
early stages but all the way up to
full development which it's about 16 to
17 days
so they had to stop by about the
ninth day i believe because it was not
simply not possible to put the whole
embryo inside
very small cuvette that you had on these
old opt scanners
and i had built this fairly large
cuvette
or acquired this very large cuvette for
my scanner and i was
you know testing how big a sample i
could put in there
so we were actually able to image really
very large
all the way up to four centimeters long
which is the full
term and now we're really talking you
know if if this is a zebrafish embryo
this is
this is a dwarf compared to these giants
and
and keep in mind that you you do obtain
image
images that contain all of the
information inside samples
so this these are already
three-dimensional reconstructions done
from the images in this case you see
here again a few artifacts obtained from
the fact that there were you know
bubbles in your
this air bubbles in the sample when we
mounted it
and then accidentally i was um given
this
rabbit embryo which i i don't really
know
the stage it's probably approaching term
um and and that bit my record that went
up to 4.5 centimeters
really interesting i i back then i had
no idea that anyone that ever tried to
image this and again keep in mind
this gives you all the anatomical
information all the detail inside this
um this rabbit embryo as well
to obtain an image like this on an on a
2000 euro
opt scanner takes about
one hour at probably even less than one
hour these days with the gpus that we
have
with the graphical processing units that
we have in most
computers um
so how far can we go and again um
by luck or serendipity i was also
given this duck
um probably very close to full term
um which we were able to image
and actually you have the setup in here
where we that we use the imageview so
now we're talking about 10
centimeters a full 100 millimeters is a
really
you put in the microscope and more
recently
through a collaboration with a colleague
we actually started looking at these
shark embryos and this is one of the
later stages that we've done it's
actually
like a day after being born um
it's more than 10 centimeters long
actually and you can see that with the
optical tomography technique
you've been seeing here in this movie
you can see all of the anatomical
details inside
but the resolutions down to 10 15
microns
you can see here you know you don't get
that much resolution from looking at
this image but i will show you in a
moment
the level of detail you can get when
everything works beautifully
now for developmental biologists optical
tomography has another interesting lure
is the fact that you don't even
need and i mentioned this before you
don't even need to stain
your samples you can actually use just
transmitted light
as long as there's a little bit of um of
contrast
you can always generate a
three-dimensional image
so if if you're using non-model species
bizarre species
that where you cannot get easily get
transgenics expressing fluorescent
proteins
you can still get a three-dimensional
image from them using optical tomography
whereas it would not be possible to get
3d images or not
easy at all to get 3d images using you
know the conventional confocal to photon
or
even lychee microscopy
developmental biologists often also use
stains like these bone and cartilage
stains
to look for developmental defects and
you can actually image these as well
this is an actual image of
one of the verse our versions of optical
tomography scanning
where you can look at a chick head
stained for with awesome green and
lizard in red
to look for cartilage and and bone and
if you can obtain images from all of the
angles if if it's transparent enough
that you can see
through it you can reconstruct it in 3d
and then obtain measurements from this
in three dimensions
the alternative to doing this would be
to use for example a synchrotron
facility which
you know every sample will cost you
thousands of errors and days of imaging
it's extremely cumbersome as i said
before
with less than 2000 euros you can build
in fact in some cases with as little as
a thousand errors you can build a setup
that will allow you to do this imaging
now just give you another example of
another project that we've worked on
there was this challenging toadfish um
here in portugal and a group from the
university of lisbon came
for our help because it was you know
it's possible to obtain images on your
stereo scope with this but you cannot
actually
see inside and see the anatomical
details and they were actually
interested in the development of hearing
and sound production
abilities of these um toad fish and
just to give you an example so if you
put this on a force on stereoscope this
is what you see if you put a confocal
microscope we're not talking a micro
microscope you get a little bit more
detail obviously you can do some
form of three-dimensional imaging but
you're using very low numerical aperture
objectives
so you're very limited in your ability
to do direct
optical slicing with optical tomography
you compromise the resolution
a little bit but because you can
actually do
isometric optical slice reconstruction
of the whole even five millimeter or
even
three centimeter long embryos you can
actually get a lot more detail than you
get with the confocal micro
microscope and we demonstrated that
publication a few years ago
and the this here is just represented
some of the stages that we were able to
image
from one month to one and a half months
to three months where there are
these gigantic 2.5 centimeter long
um animals already freely swimming and
producing sounds like as
as i said the group was actually
interested in the development of the
hearing apparatus and sound protection
apparatus
so this image here just shows you the
amount of detail you can get from those
images that you see that you've seen
before where you can
reconstruct the swim bladder measure its
length its volume
everything including the hearing
apparatus
inside the embryo and you can even
generate something really cool which is
a 3d pdfs
that you can put with your um
with your publications and because the
images are isometric you can
rotate them from any angle and you
always get the same kind of resolution
it's very precise for making
measurements that don't you know
lose quality as you rotate the sample
from sideways
which is what would happen to most of
the cases where you if you're using a
micro
confocal or if you were trying to do
thailand's teaching on your
regular confocal or two-photon
microscope
now more recently we decided that
we wanted to continue pushing the limits
of the
sizes of samples that we can image with
a setup
but not lose track of the fact that we
don't just want to image large samples
we also want to
image details inside these large samples
and you know optical tomography and
logic microscopy
at some cases being portrayed as being
competitive techniques they're not
they're really not competitive
techniques
they don't exist to compete with one
another they
they're complementary techniques and in
that respect it makes perfect sense to
actually have
a mesoscope that can do both light sheet
and optical tomography
whereas for example you can obtain a
whole image
of a whole animal with a whole embryo
during development
using transmitted light but then just
focus
and a specific group of cells that
you're interested in or an organ or
a tissue that you can follow through
fluorescence microscopy if you have a
transgenic expressing just on your
tissue or cells of interest and that's
what we've been working on now with the
help of awesome globs so we recently
joined the lab
um by using this dual setup so the
sample sits in here
and you have a 4 or 10x magnification
light sheet set up on this side with the
lace is eliminating on this plane here
and then on this side you have the
stereo version of the optical tomography
side or arm as we call it and the sample
is suspended
by this motor is rotated so you can do
multi-view reconstruction
using light sheet microscopy if
necessary but in most of the cases what
we're aiming for actually is not having
to do
multi-view reconstruction because you
can get three-dimensional reconstruction
of the whole
embryo using the optical tomography
setup and as you see
with optical tomography you can use
small cheap cameras whereas
with the lychee microscope you typically
have to resort to
you know high sensitivity cameras more
expensive cameras and here just for
presenting on the tip
of this of the snout of this short
embryo
you can see that you can get you know
fairly good
resolution that with optical tomography
these are images of optical tomography
and they're fully isometric no matter
which angle you look from which plane
you're trying to
re-slice your sample you get always the
same kind of detail
for more detail we can resort to spim
light sheets
illumination and then you get even more
detail and that's what we're working on
the challenge then is to actually
combine the two images
and keep them on the on the same data
set so to speak
which you can still do using fiji these
days and
and big that the viewer for example or
other software solutions
so that's pretty much what we've been
working on i would just like to end by
highlighting the strengths and the
limitations of optical tomography for
to try to convince you whether you
should or you should not get into it
um as i said it's very easy and cheap to
build and implement
there are multiple open source solutions
out there the one that we developed
called opent
is just one of them it's much easier to
operate and maintain than a light sheet
microscope or even an open spin
or a micro spin
even though these have different
applications once again i don't want to
portray optical tomography as
a competitive as a competitor but if
if you're venturing for the first time
into building something in your lab
and and if all you need is you know low
magnification
and not high resolution cellulose of
cellular level
information if all you want is to
reconstruct organs in 3d
on a large embryo maybe optical
tomography is just enough for you
and it's much easier to build as i said
and operate
it doesn't require lasers or complex
optics or even sensitive cameras
um it has this added value of allowing
you to do 3d imaging using bright fields
so you don't have to do staining which
can be fairly challenging
on very large embryos or even producing
transgenics
frozen proteins just out of fluorescence
is another and if you don't want to use
other fluorescence even bright field is
enough
in some cases bright field might
actually be more powerful than doing
fluorescence because
if you're doing red shifted illumination
you can actually image deeper and see
details deeper
into uh into the samples um i've also
mentioned this
great advantage is the fact that you
have inherently isometric
reconstructions
no matter which angle you choose to see
the slices from
um you will get the same quality which
is not true of
you know even light cheap microscopy
unless you do multi-view reconstruction
and multi-viewer construction is
cumbersome
it takes quite a while it's data hungry
it requires very fast computers
and very often you don't you don't get
real isometric reconstruction from the
samples it's fairly complex to do that
um so the one thing that is typically
seen as a disadvantage of optical
tomography it's the fact that you don't
get instant gratification you don't get
immediate
optical slices if you consider that you
have to do multiview reconstruction with
logic microscopy through these
mesoscopic samples
so that also is computation that also
requires time
and so in in a way the fact that you get
immediately a symmetric reconstructions
may can actually also be seen as a
strength of optical tomography you're
done you reconstruct but you're done
no not everything is
easy obviously there are some
limitations the
fact that you need to see through
require that you have to kill things and
make them transparent
um and because you have to see through
the whole sample
typically you have to resort to low
numerical aperture objectives low
magnifications which don't give you know
the high
cellular and subcellular resolution
which you might or might not require
it also severely limits your ability to
capture photons
so uh you very often resort to long
exposures and you have sort of bleaching
and that is a problem that you need to
address
occasionally with optical tomography now
if you don't use it correctly
it does generate lots of artifacts and
you have to do
fairly familiar with optical
microscopy sorry with image processing
techniques
and applying image processing techniques
to avoid some of these artifacts but
um bear in mind that's reality also if
you're doing
mesoscopic imaging with spin or even
convocal or to photon imaging
now the the the one thing that takes
people off from
trying to do optical tomography is the
fact that
it requires this filtered back
projection reconstruction to obtain the
optical slices
um but you know we've been trying to
convince people this is actually not
that
difficult i'm a biology researcher i
didn't have computer training computer
science training
and i was able to figure this out with
the help of colleagues so if you
if you do want to venture into this you
can start by searching our publication
in 2013
there's also now another open source
project
um called optij which is um fairly easy
to use as well if you want to implement
and learn how to reconstruct things
completely with like with the sorry
optical tomography
um and there's a new chapter coming out
we just had a new chapter that's coming
out on a book
very soon so contact us if you want more
information this chapter actually
describes every step and it provides you
with places where you can get the
software
to make these three-dimensional
reconstructions so i hope i was able to
convince you that optical tomography is
interesting enough that
it might be worth it to look into and i
just want to finish
by thanking um the funding that made
this process
this project possible and then also
nikon who
gave us a price for this beautiful image
of the coil emitter that
you saw in the beginning of the of the
talk and and also
many of the collaborators who have given
us samples and provided us with
challenges
for these images and and some of the
people i've had the privilege to work
with
in this project and other projects
[Music]
most of them have left the institute but
i've been lucky enough that
every time someone goes away i get
another
chance to work with another person and
now we have alex and very soon we're
going to have another
person working on this project and also
i would like to thank the rest of the
team for the support and the discussions
throughout these years
and again thank you all for taking the
time to watch this webinar
stay safe